that's for people who are online my
microphone off for a second they didn't
miss that much just basically we're
gonna explain about the difference and
today oh it's a special class because
we're actually going to be making
something real uh cs109 has the
wonderful honor of being the place where
the Stanford eye test came from where we
think about probability under
uncertainty about whether or not a
person can see based on responses to
whether guessing different letters at
different sizes
um
and I always want to make this a class
demo and now it is
and really the probability question that
you're going to have to think through is
you have a belief about how well
somebody can see
that user that is presented with a
letter
we're going to decide how uh the size of
that letter in a future class but the
user sees a letter and then they either
get it correct or wrong
um there's a version of this where like
there's an e up down right or left
you're like what is that is that some
weird W no that's supposed to be an e or
facing up and then the user is supposed
to guess up left right or down and if
they get it wrong your job is to update
your belief in how well you think that
the user can see given that they just
got that particular letter size wrong
and of course this is very interesting
uh because then you could figure out how
well somebody could see over the course
of a longer test we'll learn how to do
exactly that today we'll do something
incredibly real incredibly practical in
cs109 this Monday
where are we in cs109 we're learning
about probabilistic models and it's such
an
um a wonderful time to be studying today
we're going to continue our learning
goal of just combining Bayes theorem and
random variables in fact this task of
inference is really just that what
happens to random variables When You
observe information about other random
variables
a little bit of review before we jump in
uh I have this fun little Story Once
Upon a Time wait
was it last time no a few times ago when
I was teaching 109 I was gonna have a
baby and so my wife was really pregnant
and I really wanted to figure out what's
the chance of this baby showing on the
due date or not on the due date and
because I'm a total nerd I made a graph
and so this graph is an interesting
graph this is the probability
distribution of when a baby shows up
where zero is their actual due date you
know babies are given due dates
most babies are not born on their due
dates in fact more baby like the most
common date to be born is like four days
after your due date am I making sense
imagining babies is not that common in
your guys's lives but you guys can
imagine babies and due dates this is
making sense okay
so this is the full distribution gotten
from empirical data for uh quite a lot
of years there's been many babies and we
feel like this is the natural
distribution of when babies arrive
relative to their due dates
but the interesting question to me was
how does this probability change when I
observed that the current date is like
here
let's say the current date is here
how does this probability change you
know like if the current date is here is
it possible for the baby to have been
born here oh assuming that there's no
baby
so far
no you kind of have this thing where
like if the current date is here you
kind of know an updated belief of all
these should be zero
um
if the current date is here you kind of
feel like these probabilities should
change
but it's a little bit unclear how they
will change
and Bayes theorem does give us this
answer
um so I'm going to let you guys sit with
this for a second you know warm up talk
to the person with next year and then
I'll tell you the answer in just a
moment
um but let's say d is the day when the
baby comes and I want to know what's the
probability of this random variable
that's the task we're continuing to
learn about
um given that you observe no child so
far up to this date
I'm going to give you the hint that a
lot of times we're going to be using
Bayes theorem
so we have a prior belief about this the
probability of the child being born at a
particular date
and what's the probability of no child
so far given that the baby is actually
born on a certain date is something you
can think about
if you think about these two things
you're making good progress you're just
left with this awful normalization
constant and I want you to just take a
moment with the person next to you and
try and think about wait do I actually
know how I can get this term and can I
figure out how I would get that term
think about what the person next to you
and if you're feeling super Advanced you
don't have to do this what would you do
about this denominator
okay go for it have a nice little
conversation let's have
it
right
okay
this is a warm-up but I I will note it's
a pretty hard warm-up um and to give you
an idea of how hard it is the first time
this problem was posed to me was a year
before my baby was born when a colleague
had a baby that was about to be born and
they came to me with this problem
they're like hey Chris it's past the due
date and I need to know the distribution
of when the baby comes so I can think
about like my my midterm exam and so you
imagine as a college in the Cs
Department someone who thinks about this
stuff and it's a little bit tricky to
come up with
first of all did anyone have any
questions about where you would get this
term from
anything confused this term is the this
is my prior belief before I had any
information and that's what we call this
term this is the prior it's just a
lookup
you know if D was equal to five you
would be just looking up what's the
value of five in your prior that's all
that is it's a lookup of your belief
before you see evidence now this term is
a little bit wild and this definitely is
more you need to think about what it
means uh then there is an equation for
you to find
here's an easier one to think about
let's say that the baby is really going
to be born on day five
or sorry let me
let's say the baby was really going to
be born on date negative 43. so put in
negative 43 for a little d
what's the probability of no child so
far at this point
so the baby was really born here what's
the chance that you haven't seen the
child so far
zero okay that was good now what if I
flip it over here what if I say the
baby's really going to be born here
what's the chance that I've seen no
child so far at this point
okay very good I thought that was
actually really tricky but this value
will either be one or a zero you either
you know definitely haven't seen a child
or you definitely have seen the child
depending on whether or not you've
passed the date that the child's born
super hard to think about but what good
practice for going between the world of
probability and the real world
so this is pretty great we can take
every prior belief in either multiply it
by zero or one and we're left with this
awful awful term on the bottom
no child so far not conditioned on
knowing when the baby is born
oh did anyone have a good way we could
do this so probably no child
uh is the probability of no child so far
I only think about that for a second
I don't know when
ah no it's not one because if the baby's
this is weird this is why this term is
called normalization content it's very
strange to Think Through you're not
conditioning on when the baby is
actually born so it's possible in this
term this term is still accepting that
it's possible that the baby could be
born before
so you know little capital D could equal
to negative 47 in this term weird one to
think about
is there another way we can get rid of
it
um I was thinking that for this
bit of the area under the curve should
always be equal to your body that's a
very cool insight and it's deeper than
uh you might feel at first blush
it must be the true that the area of
this probability Mass function must
equal to one you know how this term is
called the normalization constant it
gets that name because a lot of people
find that the best way to calculus is to
figure out what value makes all of this
equal to one
there's a different way of getting to
that exact same answer which is what I
have to do now is I have to do a law of
total probability over D and this is
going to be the log total probability of
the probability of no child so far
so far given D equals D if you you know
law of total probability of this you'll
end up with the exact same result of
just treating it like a normalization
constant so if you multiplied all of
these you would get some distribution
and the normalization constant will be
whatever number it needs to be such that
if you summed up all of these terms it
would come to one
and I think that is exactly the right
way to think about it as a way I was
hoping you guys would think about
um
oh at this point you guys might have
noticed there's a massive vertical bar
up here so I really cared about this
like I was doing this for my wife and
myself so like I wanted to get things
right does anyone have a guess for why
there's this like massive vertical bar
and why the distribution doesn't just
keep going it's not just like a
truncated version
yeah naturally humans can have babies
after this point
so this is the due date and then like
after this point babies can have it can
come was it the day after which she
would just have a C-section yeah or it's
not a C-section it turns out if a baby
in in most countries if a baby is really
really late they'll give you a drug that
induces delivery and so they kind of
make the baby come so this is the date
of induction so that actually is just
the sum of all the probabilities of that
date or afterwards we've got a little
bit too deep into babies but if there
was one major takeaway here it's really
this one
that one way to think about this
normalization term is it is the term
that allows the whole probably Mass
function to come to one
which is a cool new angle on that term
yes
yeah if you think about it um
the pr any probably Mass function like
your belief in D at any point in time if
you Loop over all values of D if you sum
those up it should be equal to one
because D is going to take on some value
um and so one way to think about is
there's some unknown term here K like if
you just call this K you say there's
some unknown term k but I know that
probably if D given no child so far if I
summed over all values of T it should
come to one that would allow me to solve
for what K is
I can then say you know um the sum over
all of these uh terms should be equal to
one and then you can solve for uh k
yes
integrating from the left hand side up
until the current date or for the
current date of right and this one's
going to be integrating over all the
possible days that are still left
um so it's it really is integrating over
no child so far over all the values
given the values
or today
today
so far yes that's right okay okay
good we'll come back to this in a
non-gated version and but if there's one
major takeaways I want you to start
thinking about new ways
okay and a little bit more review
um we talked about Bayes theorem a long
time ago we talked about random
variables take on values our events and
so we can think about hey what's the
probability of this event that M this
discrete random variable takes on the
value 2 given that this other random
variable takes on the value three and we
could just use Bays it's just events
now more generally you start to see
things like what we had in the previous
slide where you have random variable
takes on any value given other random
variable takes on any value and you have
to like generally solve for whatever
insertion to n and whatever's insertion
to M this is more general statement but
the reason that the Bayes theorem works
the same is because this really is an
event it's just an event with an unknown
input so far
shorthand will often be used when you
get to these complicated statements
because people don't write like to write
random variable M takes on non-random
input variable Little M so you'll often
see this shorthand when people write
this up
and then on Friday we took this up a
notch we started thinking not just about
discrete random variables but continuous
random variables and we had this nice
result which is Bayes theorem Works
whether or not you have a discrete
random variable m
or you have a continuous random variable
X so if they're both discrete you just
get exactly the base theorem you thought
but if one of them is continuous you get
Bayes theorem
it just happens that when you're talking
about the continuous random variable
instead of using the probability Mass
function you use the probably density
function so the probably density
function is like your expression of
likelihood for a continuous random
variable and probably Mass function is
the expression of likelihood for a
discrete random variable intuitively
this feels very good and then we
mathematically showed why it's true and
it just doesn't matter what combination
of continuous and randoms you have as
long as the thing on the left hand side
of the bar is continuous use density and
if the thing on the left hand side of
the bar is discrete then you use
probability Mass
so base it works in all the ways you'd
want just if something's continuous use
probability density
okay and that works true for the law of
total probability
so if you want to know like the density
at X you could use a lot of total
probability over some discrete random
variable n again you just use density
when you have a continuous random
variable and use probability Mass when
you have a discrete random variable
okay and then in class we worked on this
problem we thought what's the
probability of the gender of an elephant
given the weight of the elephant we've
told that you know gender equals one has
this weight distribution gender equals
zero has this weight distribution and we
want to just infer the probably
distribution over G given an observation
to X
and I want to lightly point out that
I've told you before if you have
multiple random variables the thing you
would need to solve anything is this
thing called a joint
and the joint says what's the likelihood
of particular combinations to random
variables so like g equals one and x
equals 72.3 you've given me assignment
to all the random variables and you
should be able to talk about the
probability of those two things together
and we do have that in the problem
because we could decompose this like the
probability of the gender and then the
probability of the weight given the
gender and so because the problem has
given us the probability of the gender
check and the probability of a weight
given the gender then we could figure
out exactly the joint probability I just
want to note that it's implicitly there
and you could do this more generally
but if you want to solve this problem
what we did in last class is we set up a
base theorem we said we want to know
probably if g equals one given a
particular weight since we had
probability g equals one given x equals
163.
and that was equal to the density of x
equals 163 given g equals one
probability that g equals one
and then here we had we could use a law
of total probability for the classic
version of Bayes that we love
163 given g equals 1.
times probably g equals one
plus the density of x equals 163 given g
equals zero
times probably g equals zero
so if just beta's theorem is just our
events our assignments to random
variables and in this case where we have
a continuous random variable on the left
we use the PDF what's the PDF here oh
that's a little scary
why is it a little scary because you're
like um what is that well X is a normal
if g equals one then we know that X is
this normal and you know what normals
have
oh sad times
what do normals have
a probability density function they have
a cumulative density function and then
probably density function and what
you're going to put in right there is
that normal PDF
what a time to be alive
um I'm going to get more into this
Wednesday but I'm going to start showing
you that when you have big models of
lots of random variables there is this
way of visually drawing them and because
they gave you gender and then they gave
you weight given gender this picture is
actually implicitly behind the scenes
that we imagine that the gender is
what's causing weight and so that you
can give the joint by first giving the
gender and then the weight given the
gender that's not that important right
now but it will be more important on
Wednesday
okay
wow what a lot
I do want to give us one more piece of
practice
on Friday's class we did this project
where
um we thought about the situation of
trying to decide if a baby can hear or
not so play a sound and then the baby
will look up or not based on whether or
not they hear the sound but we have this
problem that sometimes babies look up
when they don't hear the sound and
sometimes babies uh won't look up when
they do hear the sound there's some
stochasticity even though there's a
probably a distribution so if you want
to infer whether or not a baby can hear
given their response to sound we need to
use probability
but now I'm going to bump this up a not
CH so for babies who can hear sound when
a sound is played their gaze moves by a
continuous random variable
so if you play a sound there's a good
chance that their gaze moves by 15 units
and there's some variance to it it's
possible that their gaze moves by zero
units possible it could be negative if a
baby can't hear sounds there's still a
distribution for how much they move
their head it's just a different
distribution
so if a baby moves their head 14 degrees
after you play a sound you can't
conclude
with certainty whether or not the baby
can hear but you can update your
probability
so my question for you guys a little bit
of practice is under this normal
assumption where we're given
distributions of how much babies move
when the sound is played can you update
your belief so again take a little time
for practice I'm actually going to give
you guys a minute and a half to think
about this because I think it's very
important in fact some of the hardest
problems on the midterm often take this
form so if you can if you feel
uncomfortable with it great you have
something to study and if you don't feel
uncomfortable with it wonderful you're
in a very very good place in cs109 so
let's see if we can think this through
how could you figure it out okay
I'll race the board what we think about
it
sure
thank you
instructions
how am I supposed to complete
probabilities
foreign
but if we want to be able to do that
Stanford Acuity test we need to get very
comfortable with inference because right
now I'm going to tell you what we're
doing here is we're updating the belief
of a Bernoulli given the observation of
a continuous and we want to do the
Stanford eye test we're going to have to
be able to update a belief about
something much more complicated than a
Bernoulli so you really want to feel
comfortable in this space before we can
do something more complicated I know
this is hard
okay but at the same time it's not that
impossible you just have to follow the
recipe the recipe often involves your
first step is to write your random
variables like if you get to a midterm
problem you don't know what to do write
random variables you'll probably get
some extra or like partial credit even
if you don't get the answer past this
point but Define your random variables
really matters and once you define your
random variables then write what the
question is asking in terms of those
random variables and in fact then you've
really set yourself up for success
so if I say h is a 1 if the baby can
hear I'm going to say it's a Bernoulli
random variable you could have had an
event without a random variable here but
I'm going to get in the practice of
using random variables in place of
events and if it's just binary I'll use
a Bernoulli
so what's the problem that H equals one
given that x equals what was X
14.
that's what we want you to calculate
and the only reason this is a little bit
difficult is because the thing you're
conditioning on is continuous
so you have this continuous belief over
how much the baby's view will change
and because that's continuous we're
gonna have to use that other version of
Bayes where we don't use the probably
Mass function we use probably density
function
so I hope when you guys got to this
point a natural thing to do was f of x
equals 14 given H equals one
times the probability that H equals one
divided by and we can call this a
normalization constant or you can expand
it out
um
you can expand it out by thinking about
the case where H equals zero and k
equals H equals one there's several ways
you could deal with this
the probability that H equals one that's
your prior belief I think I forgot to
mention here but we're going to assume a
one-half prior this is a pretty safe
assumption if you don't have a belief
otherwise
but then we still need to put in this
term
and for this term I've told you that the
child is hearing so when the condition
gets flipped you're told what is the
state of this unobserved hearing
variable you're told that hearing is in
fact one and then it's How likely is X
to be 14 if hearing is one can somebody
help help me out here what what is this
and actually if you had to write this in
Python it'd be like uh PSI Pi dot Norm
dot PDF
and what are the values of norms PDF
you have to say what is the value it's
taking on
you have to say what is the mean of the
distribution what's the mean of this
distribution
yeah
because we know H equals one we know
we're talking about this normal not that
normal and then uh you have to put in
the other parameter which is
annoyingly in sci-fi the square root of
the variance
now you could have written that
or instead of writing that you could
have written what this actual
mathematical equation is if you want to
write what that actual mathematical
equation is we have it right here it's 1
over Sigma square root
Sigma is the square root of 50 and then
you have the square root of 2 pi
e to the power of negative
14 is X
minus the mean divided by
uh the standard deviation which is the
square root of 50 squared did I miss
anything there oh the minus one half
and you can put that term in and you
multiply it by one half a nice thing is
if you followed through with this
problem
all of these terms would end up
canceling out and you just get this nice
little expression on the top and you get
similar Expressions on the bottom
we haven't dealt with the bottom turn
but as I said you could just expand it
out by thinking about the case for H
equals one and the case where H equals
zero like our classic
um Bayes theorem
but I know this is hard so what I want
you guys to do is I want you guys to
tell me what's confusing about this like
what what's hard about this what could I
go deeper into
so how would you like
good question the good question is how
would I do this on a midterm like I
can't calculate this by hand you don't
need to calculate this by hand so
there's two valid ways you could answer
this problem midterm this is an answer
on the midterm like that would be like
the answer would be you know assuming
you fill in the denominator that's the
answer we would be looking for and you
don't have to solve it
the other thing is if there's a time
where you want to use a python function
we'll let you use a python function we
just kind of assume you would be able to
use a computer if we gave you one so if
you say like you know calculate this
using scipy I'm fine with that too
okay yes
you have you're using all pmfs in this
case we're using PDFs
um but PDFs don't return probabilities
right
that's right they give you back
probability densities and it's amazing
that if you multiply this probably
density Pi this probability and you
divide by this probability and so you're
still left with a probability
um and that does come from the fact
um that there is this Epsilon trick we
used in the derivation
um and that Epsilon trick is allowing
this probably density to convert to a
probability and back so if you check out
the derivation there's a nice reason for
y but you're absolutely right it's just
not a problem which is a beautiful thing
and it's mind-blowing beautiful
wonderful thing that you should use in
your life and on the mature question yes
can you explain again why p h equals one
is one half oh that's a this is your
prior belief in whether or not the child
you hear before you see any evidence so
it's like you haven't even met the child
what's your belief that they can hear uh
and sometimes you have reason for a
deeper belief in what your prior is and
sometimes you don't and if you don't
have a deeper belief than like the
uniform prior is pretty reasonable so
the probability that H equals one equals
probably H equals zero seems very
reasonable to me
the problem figure that otherwise it's
the problem
is
ah so the senior isn't really helping us
here this evening was such a beautiful
thing if we wanted to answer probably
questions about it normal like what's
probably that a normal takes on a value
in a particular range but the CDF
doesn't even come in here
um I suppose
if I told you like what's the
probability of hearing given that the
child heard
you know moved less than 14 degrees then
that would allow you to use like the CDF
on this side but
um
yeah a lot of times with Bayes theorem
the PDF is more useful so the PDF you
needed to know it for this reason
okay you guys are wonderful I know this
is hard but those two problems if you
could go practice them I think
uh you'll really appreciate that come
Tuesday
again I just want to note gently note
that there is this implied way of
expressing The Joint distribution here
we're saying that we think it's the
hearing that causes the Gaze change and
so first you want to know the hearing
and once you know the hearing the
knowing the Gaze change is a little bit
more straightforward and there's kind of
this implied causality and we're going
to get way deeper into that in
Wednesday's class but um they give you
the joint by telling you the probability
of hearing and then the probability of
gays change given hearing as I said if
you want to solve all probability
questions you want the problem ask her
to have given you the full joint
distribution
okay
are you guys ready
we are going to bump this up a notch
these have been hard problems but
there's one thing that's made them easy
here than what we're about to do the
thing that makes it easier than what
we're about to do is a lot of times what
was on this left hand side was just a
Bernoulli
it's like you had one belief value and
it was updating and now I want us to
think about what happens when your
belief distributions not a Bernoulli and
we're going to be doing this by coming
up with a better eye test so in cs109 we
started using probability think about
estimating how well somebody could see
so you can go to my eyes dot Ai and you
can run this cs109 algorithm and if you
go to run that cs109 algorithm as you
answer questions you can watch the
belief distribution how well you can see
change this is the old problem where
we're solving has anyone ever taken one
of these eye tests
oh brutal right they like ask you this
row and then they ask you this row and
then they ask you this row and there's
two big issues here like it doesn't
allow for you to ask questions that are
between these font sizes and then a lot
of times there's stochasticity and
Randomness that's not being taken into
account when they score you based on
this exam like maybe you kind of see the
number and you're guessing
maybe you make a mistake and you kind of
knew the letter but you said it wrong
anyways and without thinking about all
this probability they actually end up in
the wrong answer a lot of time so this
is an explanation of like what 109 is
able to do
this is your normal eye exam 20 is the
normal amount of letters that you have
to answer
and on the y-axis is how wrong it is you
want to be low on the y-axis and this is
pretty high this is relative error is
just like the percentage difference
between what the exam says you can see
and how well you can actually see so you
can see there's kind of some error it's
not 100 but it's notable and you know
longer tests don't really help that much
if you want to do a clinical trial you
use the much bigger version of the exact
same test but it still has pretty high
error
there is this really cool dude in
Switzerland who came up with this
algorithm that we learned about later
and that algorithm didn't use a lot of
probability Theory but it did some nice
adaptive answering but then we came up
in cs109 with the one that used the nice
probability theorem and you see we can
get like way way way reduced uh error
rates
and it all just comes from a little bit
of thinking about probability and you'll
be surprised how simple it is like
you're like hey it's just Bayes theorem
with a nice little normalization mind
blown and like you know from 1800 until
2000 I think it was two years ago people
just didn't think about applying base
theorem in this way
okay
so let's tell you this story and I'm
going to give you a way of representing
how well somebody could see
we're going to represent how well
somebody can see as a random variable
and we're going to consistently use the
random variable name a to represent how
well someone can see a can you think of
it as ability or if you're really fancy
you can think about as a cutie Acuity is
a really technical term for ability to
see or that's visual acuity
so this is a random variable it's a
random variable and therefore you want
to give the whole distribution
if that random variable is continuous
you should be giving a probability
density if that random variable is
discrete you should be giving you know
some function that a probably Mass which
which represents whether or not or the
different assignments a little a to
their probabilities
this is the cheekiest thing that we did
ability to see really should be
continuous so if zero is like you can't
see at all and one is standard vision
ability to see in the natural world is
continuous but to solve this problem we
did something that you guys probably
desire to do many times when you see
continuous random variables
we discretized it we said sure it's
continuous but what if we represent as
like 200 points so we can say like or
let's say 100 points so you have a
billion series zero a bill you'll see a
0.01 ability to 0.02
we took something that's truly
continuous and made discrete by making a
hundred little bins and we thought about
you know if your true ability to see a
0.2222222 we'll just truncate that to
0.02
wild does that make sense
okay then as soon as I tell you that now
you have a discrete distribution and
what I'm showing you is your prior
belief in the ability of someone to see
so this comes from historical data we've
got lots of data from around the world
of people's ability to see and here's
what that prior belief looks like what
is this prior belief thing is it saying
that more people can't see or that more
people can see like when someone walks
into this exam are you more likely to
believe that somebody can or cannot see
I'm just going to give you guys a second
to think about this because it's
important we're going to build on this
chart a lot uh in the lecture
low probability here high probability
here
we think that most people walking into
this tent this test can see you can
change your priors priors are you know
philosophical different people could say
well I think my particular Clinic has a
prior that looks like this or you can
say I don't want to make any assumptions
so originally I'm going to assume
everything's equally likely all valid
priors but what we're going to be using
first is the historical prior so like
this is the prior of abilities of people
to see yes
when doing that would
you too
um the value with the top probability
such a good question
I'm so glad you asked that okay so
there's when you talk about how well
somebody could see a lot of us think
about number
but from today on in cs109 I want you to
think about the whole random variable if
he says what's your somebody says what's
your belief that somebody can see it's
not a number it's a whole distribution
and that distribution relates all
possible numbers to their corresponding
probabilities if you force me to choose
a number I could choose expectation or I
could choose mode
but never force me to choose a number I
would much rather have a random variable
than a number because a random variable
keeps tracks of all the possibilities
that it could take on it keeps track my
own uncertainty that maybe somebody you
really could see not very well and so I
love random variables and I think if you
reduce it to a number you've just lost
so much and there's a little tear in my
eye when somebody makes me do that but
uh that's not important right now
okay other questions about this
okay
now in your computer we haven't talked
too much about how this gets represented
in computers but if I'm representing
this probability belief in a computer
and if I've discretized it there's a
pretty reasonable way that I could
represent this I could represent it as a
dictionary
so a dictionary has keys and value Pairs
and so I'm gonna have a dictionary where
if you put 0.09 in for the key I'm going
to give you back the prior belief
this one's calculated for you from
historical data but this is how we're
going to be representing our random
variable does that make sense like
Ensemble it might be intuitive but again
there might be something confusing is
there anything confusing about this
you could have written this yourself if
I gave you the data but that's not what
we're going to focus on today
okay you guys following along so far
please ask me questions because I will
just keep building
so again your prior belief you can
represent it as a graph you can
represent it as a dictionary but these
are just two different representations
for the same thing they're both
representing the random variable and
they're both representing for any
assignment what is the corresponding
probability
okay this is not that important but
there's a doctor in the room I know you
guys who love rhythmic units and I've
simplified this a little bit for class
so just before you use this in a real
medical case just come talk to me okay
now
you had that prior belief so before the
patient walked in you had a belief about
how well they can see let's say to start
off you show them this font size so
there's a particular font size 0.7 and
they get it wrong
getting it wrong we're going to
represent as there's a random variable y
y equals one means they got it right y
equals zero means they got it wrong You
observe that they got it wrong what
happens to your belief
and as soon as you hear those words I
want you guys to start dreaming of Bayes
theorem you're like I have a random
variable I observe something and I want
to change my belief in the random
variable that's exactly where this
wonderful equation is most useful
I will let you know that if we did Bayes
theorem correctly you know you'll watch
your distribution change they just saw a
really large letter and they got it
wrong
so now it starts to become really
believable that they can't see that well
whereas in our prior we thought most
people could see pretty well now that
they got a big letter wrong we're like
uh oh we're not going to rule out the
chance that maybe you could see pretty
well you just got unlucky
but now we start to believe okay maybe
we're talking to somebody who doesn't
see it that well like me
so if I could put this together all in
one chart it looks like this you have a
prior belief
then you see an observation that's a
particular font size they got it wrong
and then you want to update your belief
um oh well ours had something that was a
little flatter because I put in two
different numbers when making these
slides but your updated belief looks
like
this is
and the way we're going to get there is
through base
and base says
this thing I care about the belief and
ability to see given your observation is
hard to think about but the flip is much
easier the probability of seeing this
observation given I tell you how well
somebody can see
you have to have a prior belief
and you have to deal with the
normalization constant but we're going
to use that idea from beginning of the
warm-up that this is just going to be
whatever number we need it to be such
that for all values of a this thing sums
to one it will truly be a normalization
so hopefully you guys see that this is a
cool thing to have
like how nice would that be so hope
that's what I want you to see about this
equation and I want you to see about
this term that this is something we
already have access to
somebody has told you their prior belief
if you had a particular value of 0.5 for
example you would just be looking up in
your Dictionary what is the probability
associated with 0.5 so if this is a
probably a equals 0.5 giving y equals 0
you would just look up probably equal
0.5 I'm leaving a little variable here
because I don't just want the belief of
ability taking on one number I want the
whole belief over all possible numbers I
want a whole freaking probability Mass
function
okay which must leave you with a
question which is just like uh how are
we going to get this the likelihood term
How likely is your observation given I
tell you the value of the thing you're
trying to infer the hidden variable we
often think about this thing as the
hidden variable the unobserved you can't
open up someone's eye and see how well
they can see if instead you infer it
based on evidence
I'm going to leave this here because if
there's one most important slide of
today this would be it so we should
think about it for just a second
man how many times we see base there in
this class how many times do you see
base theorem in the world there's a
beautiful book called like the theory
that will not die it's just all about
Bayes theorem and how it just shows up
every single place in the whole world
based there what a thing
okay are you guys following along so far
are you left with this mystery of where
does this equation come from
think about it semantically
I will tell you exactly how well the
person can see and then I want you to
tell me how likely it is that they got
it wrong
couple key takeaways before I talk about
this
um
that cell phone tracking problem that
you guys had to do on your problem set
was really warming you up for this world
of random variables because if you think
about it that cell phone location could
have been one random variable where it
takes on values of all those locations
we thought about it as like 16 different
events but you could really think about
it as one random variable with 16
assignments and those two things are
going to map very nicely onto each other
um
some beliefs can be represented like if
you have a random variable you really
want to function which is like the
probably Mass function the probably
density function sometimes it's hard to
represent beliefs as an equation and if
you're a computer scientist a dictionary
is a pretty cool idea for representing a
random variable I just wanted to mention
that
okay
um and then I also want to mention this
cool little trick I did which is I took
a continuous random variable and I
discretize it to make my life easier
okay and then once again there is an
implied causality in the world we are
saying that its ability to see that
causes you to get a problem correct or
not correct the converse would be pretty
ridiculous like whether or not you get
it correct
is the thing that tells you whether or
not a human can see I mean knowing this
allows you to estimate ability but in
the real world it's ability that's
causing correctness and again we'll get
more into that on Wednesday
so now let's take a moment and talk
about this equation I'm going to tell
you the real deal but I'm not going to
test you on it like on the midterm not
going to ask you about the education
theory that explains this but I want you
to understand where these could come
from are you guys ready for it
there is a world in education that talks
about exactly this and let's write about
what we're curious about
we want to know the probably that y
equals zero given ability equals a
oh sorry probability
so y equals zero given ability equals a
we're going to want to be able to do
this for any value of little a but let's
put in a concrete number so that we can
think about it
so if I tell you someone's ability to
see a zero point a what's the
probability that they get it wrong does
that make sense to people
as what we're asking okay
so
it comes back to this thing called item
response Theory item response theory is
an old theory that people have had since
the 1950s which says if you take a
person and you match them up with a
question maybe it's a question on an
exam or maybe it's a question on eye
test we can talk about the probability
that that particular person gets it
right
and since the 1950s people have been
making this assumption
every person has an ability and every
problem has a difficulty
this is really the model people use they
take the ability of the person
subtract off the difficulty of the task
and that will give you a number it's not
necessarily a probability and so they
take that number and put it through a
squashing function that gives you a
probability and if I had to plot this
particular squashing function this
sigmoid is a squashing function which is
if you put in a really large number it
gives you something close to one and if
you put in a really negative number it
gives you something close to a zero in
fact if you put in a zero it gives you a
0.5
that's the sigmoid
and the sigmoid function is basically a
really cool hack to take any number and
make it look like a probability
and that's what people use have you guys
the Adaptive GRE uses this when people
normalize on the GRE they're using this
um you know if you take the
um
I don't know any of the big tests like
the TOEFL this is the theory that people
have behind the scenes for probability
that somebody gets things right the
reason they have this theory is because
they want to figure out how difficult
their problems are and to figure out how
strong their students are
so this is a probability it says if you
tell me the difficulty and you tell me
the ability you just put this through a
function and it gives you a probability
back so the probability that y equals
zero given a equals 0.8 is just going to
be plugging into this equation you put
0.8 for the ability and then you put in
the difficulty
you're like wait what's the difficulty
well if you know the size of the letter
the difficulty is just going to be a
function of the size of the letter so
big letters are going to be thought of
as easy and small little letters are
going to be thought of as difficult you
can just imagine this is equal to 1
minus the font size
so if I tell you 0.8 and I know the font
size I can take 0.8 subtract off my
function of the font size put it through
the squashing function and I get a
probability
I'm just going to go a little bit deeper
if you guys bear with me for a second
okay any questions about this as I said
I am response Theory not on the exam
that we did like a while ago or the
question about multiple plus questions
like taking that a step forward yeah
yeah absolutely
um yes
and actually that does lead to this one
other thing so item response Theory says
the probability that person a gets I
gets question J correct is this little
nice little formula where sigmoid is not
the very it's not the standard deviation
of anything it's this particular
function
there's a little bit more to it if
you're curious we think about guessing
we add in the probability that maybe
somebody just guessed and got this
correct and we think about slipping too
slipping is when you know the answer but
you just get it wrong anyways and so you
just think about cases we think about
the probability of or it's like either
you got it right because you guessed it
right or you probably or you got it
right because you actually knew the
answer so you think about this as the
probably that people actually know the
answer and then slipping like maybe you
know the answer but then you just like
accidentally fill in the wrong thing
just because there's a 100 chance that
you just make a mistake
all of this would allow us to just have
a function where if you give me ability
I can straight up calculate the
probability that you get it right sorry
all this gives you the probability that
you get it right
and if somebody tells you that probably
you get it right and you want to know
the probability that they got it wrong
it's just going to be 1 minus that
which kind of brings us back to
you know if we go all the way back here
what I'm telling you is that we just
have a simple function if you give me
ability and you know the font size you
just put those two things into python
function it'll give you the probability
that they got it right
back and then you can do one minus that
to get the probably they got it wrong
cool aside
okay I didn't try I tried teaching this
class once before and I didn't give
people that aside I really didn't want
to lose people on it but I thought
actually you'd get more insight just
knowing a little bit deeper what goes
behind the hood you could just think of
it as the problem statement gives you
this term
or you could know the item response
theory is the the secret sauce yes
or the graph that is on the slides does
it go up again for one exactly because
it thinks somebody has slipped exactly
so here there's some probability that
they're strong in my in in the graph I
showed you and it's because it thinks
that there's a chance that somebody came
in and it was strong and then got the
question wrong only because they slipped
like they knew the answer and they just
happened to just blurt out the wrong
answer so there's still some belief that
there's strong uh visually and they just
got unlucky
that's exactly why and turns out we we
did this thing where we tested out all
of our different modeling decisions and
which ones matter the most and turns out
putting and guessing and slipping were
critical to be able to really come up
with the right answer after somebody
answers 20 questions
so there you go
okay
um
so
we're going to practice thinking about
Bayes theorem but then I also want to
point out what happens if you have
multiple observations
so we've talked about observation one so
in observation one you have a belief you
see them get some letter wrong let's say
it's at font size 0.7 and then you
update your belief using Bayes Theory
what if then you see another letter like
we give them a larger letter and they
get it correct
how do we deal with multiple
observations
because we think of each observation as
being independent given ability it turns
out this becomes just this posterior
like after you calculate this
wait for it in your second observation
it becomes your prior
so it's like in your first observation
this is your prior but then you saw
something this became your belief and
then your second observation that's now
your belief and you get a new piece of
evidence and then you change your belief
if you add a third observation this
would then become your prior
yes
because you're using like the previous
step as a prior to your next step does
it mean that about the order of the
questions might influence what the final
probability looks like because of the
independence that's actually true um it
turns out order won't matter so good
question very good question
okay
this is what okay posterior becomes our
new prior but really this is what I want
us to be able to program whether or not
somebody gets something right or wrong
for a particular font size I want us to
be able to update our belief
did you guys get our goal
and then doing multiple will be very
straightforward if we can just program
this Bayes theorem
shall we
I think we should
okay to the code
so what do I have for us to start out oh
that's our website that's also our
website
to the code here's what I have for us
so first of all I've got a function
called get prior probability
and if you call get prior probability
it will give you back a function I also
give you a function called plot which
will take this dictionary and plot it so
if I run the starter code
it just plots this is your belief
somebody walks in to the exam and
without seeing anything about their eye
this is your belief that they can see
sound good
we're then going to observe something
we're going to update our belief given
the prior and then also give an
observation an observation has two parts
hey people in the back can you guys see
this
you want font bigger just yell it my
vision's bad it's mine too I really
appreciate that this is going to be the
test for us in fact it turns out this
test is really important for people with
bad Vision uh like myself
okay
good
so
a belief has two parts or sorry an
observation has two parts when somebody
answers a question you you see two
things you know the font size of the
question that was asked and then you see
whether or not they got it correct and
the correct is going to be a Boolean
so are we going to want to write a
function called update a belief that can
take in an observation so any font size
and whether or not they got it correct
you know here's a different observation
in this observation they saw a bigger
letter and they got it correct whereas
this one they saw a slightly smaller
letter and they got it wrong the letters
go from zero to one so these are both
big letters
okay
Now update belief is really what we need
to write what I have here creates a
posterior but if you read it carefully
it Loops over every value inability so
every possible assignment to little a
and it just looks up the prior
and it says the posterior is equal to
the prior it doesn't do any updating at
all and then it Returns the posterior as
if it had done some work so cheeky it's
done nothing it's just basically copied
over the dictionary
and so if you call you know you can have
all these changes you want
oh python 3.9 I haven't installed
decanter on my python 310.
we saw all these observations and we
haven't changed our belief at all so bad
we must be more flexible we must change
our belief when we see evidence we all
must do this yes question
about the graphs are they
just stick to each
layer
ability to see
and so they're not specific to the size
of the letter at all
um you know if we go back here
I can look at one of these graphs and I
don't need to know the history of the
test that they took and I can just see
that this says you think the person can
see pretty badly
because this is poor vision and this is
good vision and it doesn't matter what
the font sizes were of the question this
is just an expression of how well a
person can see
come in different font sizes right yes
so does the letter the size of the
correct letter effective says I mean if
you've gotten to the solution and when
we get the solution right if you put in
different font sizes it's going to have
a really big impact on your belief so
like if you get a small letter wrong
that will change your belief in a really
different way than if you get a big
letter wrong but at the end of the day
we're going to be and you know plotting
these beliefs of ability to see
so it's like what happens in this middle
step is affected by the font size and it
will certainly tell you how the the
prior changes the posterior
okay
there's one other thing that I've got
for us
I wrote item response theory for you
here
I said if you give me the font size your
difficulty is equal to one minus the
font size why did they do one minus well
because large letters have large font
sizes
but they're easy
and small letters have small font sizes
but they're hard and so the one minus
allows us to say okay go from font size
to difficulty and then the sigmoid
function of a billion minus difficulty
that was item response Theory and I
totally recommend you guys think about
why I got slip times guess plus one
minus slip times the probability that
came out of item response Theory that's
a super interesting thing to think about
if you guys want to just like push
yourselves a little bit as it says not
the point of this class but I think
that's fascinating
then also the scaling factor it's like a
super extra feature of item response
Theory which we don't need to get into
but I do give you the probability of
correct given ability
but it turns out the probability of a
correct given ability is super
misleading because your observation
might not be correct
if your observation has somebody who got
it correct
you should be giving back that number
but if the person got it wrong you need
to be giving back one minus the chance
that they got it correct
so going back to the slides
item response Theory gives you the
probability that y equals one given a
equals little a
if you want the probability that y
equals zero you have to do 1 minus that
value
everything the world's a potato are not
a potato law of probability
okay so all this means that when you
package those together I give you the
probability of an observation given
ability
so probably of observation given ability
is basically writing this probability
of an observation
given an ability
so this whole expression just becomes a
function call that I give to you
and come talk to me about IM response
Theory you can go deeper into it
so now we have problems or probably of
observation given ability and our job is
to write this function
you saw an observation and you're not
going to change one ability you're going
to change your belief in the entire
ability
so we're going to calculate a posterior
we're going to Loop over every value
little a and for every value little a we
can look of its prior
and we can do one more thing we can now
call this function we can say what's the
probability
with a particular ability
of seeing this observation
so you know we're passing in this
observation
and we have a function which says what's
the probability observation given
ability
I really want you guys to think about
what this for Loop is doing
this for Loop is going over your entire
assignments of little a
so before you have this belief right
this for Loop is saying okay what if a
equals 0.0
you can look up the prior and you can
say How likely is the observation given
this value of little a and then we do
0.01 and we go through the next
iteration of the for Loop you look up
the prior belief of that it's just this
value and then you can figure out what's
the probability of this observation
given a equals 0.01 and the for loop
we're going to try every single value
there
so if we call this probability of
observation
in the Bayes theorem we have the prior
belief
I'm going to call this prior belief and
these are actually I like the little eye
because actually I'm going to call them
little A's because I feel like that's a
little bit nicer for you guys
so we're going to Loop over all the
assignments to little a
and then now we need to say what is our
posterior belief
of somebody's ability to see being equal
to that little a
I want you guys to think about what goes
in here because there's only two lines
that you would really need to make this
whole probabilistic thing work but you
need to get those two orions perfect and
so you need to go deep into your theory
so in this posterior where is this
coming from think about it with the
person next to you I'll start writing on
the board and then we can
code it up okay
is
a way that's
true
okay
if we were going back to our world of
hearing or elephant weights you don't
need a for Loop
because the values of the random
variable you're thinking about can only
take on the value of zero or one you
only need to calculate one of those so
we could do Bayes theorem without a for
Loop
but now we're inferring our belief about
a random variable called a
and a can take on a hundred values 0
0.01 0.02
and so if you want to infer a you can't
just use Bayes theorem once instead
we're going to have a for Loop and we're
going to think about for every
assignment to a what is our updated
belief that's what this for Loop is so
we're not just going to do base theorem
once we're going to do base theorem
thinking about a taking on the value of
0.0 0.01 0.02 0.03 so this overall for
Loop is going to Loop over all the
values of little a
so when I say ability a that means you
know little a we have this whole thing
is going to calculate the belief of
capital A and we're going to for Loop
over all possible values little a
for every possible value little a we
have the prior you can look up the graph
before that is your belief before you
saw this observation because don't
forget we're updating our belief in
capital A for an observation
we know if you tell me the value of
little a we can say How likely is the
observation like we're given this term
the likelihood of the observation given
a equals little a
and then Bayes theorem says you just
multiply these two together
you take your prior and multiply by the
probably the observation given your
prior
and then you solve for this
I'm going to do the cheekiest thing
I'm going to pretend that this doesn't
even exist I'm just be like I don't even
see you huh like what normalization
constant and I'm just going to do this
numerator term
and then we'll get to the wrong answer
but a helpful wrong answer
so I'm going to run this
python this is our starter code
and starter code
and this looks exactly right
it's not right if you were very careful
and you calculated the sum of all these
probabilities they won't sum to one and
if this is a proper belief then either
the area under this curve however you
like think about area under this curve
should be one
and basically this looks right but if
you were very careful the y-axis is
wrong
and it's because we didn't think about
this term
but the crazy thing is this term is the
same for every assignment of ability
little a like when ability equals 0.01
these terms change a lot but this term
stays the same when ability is 0.02
these terms change a lot but this one
stays the same when ability is 0.03 you
guys get where I'm going these ones
change a lot but how about this one
stays the same you can see why people
think about this as the normalization
constant like it's like everything is
multiplied by some unknown number
if I knew that number then I would know
this term but I'd also be able to
calculate my updated belief
but we're going to leverage the fact
that we know that all these things
should integrate to one the area under
the curve should be one so if you sum up
this Value Plus this Value Plus this
Value Plus this value it should give you
one
there's a few ways you can do this but I
chose to write a normalized function
basically I Loop over the whole
dictionary and I calculate the total
and that total will be something
different than one
but I know if I divide every belief by
this total then it turns out that
normalizes your whole histogram so the
whole thing must integrate to one you
can think about how you would like to do
this there's lots of correct ways to do
it but at the end of the day you just
need to write a function so that you
take all these terms
you take all of these terms in this
dictionary and you scale them by some
number some magical number so that if
you add up all the terms it gives you
one
and I called mine normalize
and and now we have it
and you can take one belief
you can add in another belief so this is
they got a pretty large number wrong but
then they got a bigger letter right and
then you know you can think about those
two letters in a row and like now we
think that actually they don't see that
well we are most likely a belief if you
ask me for one number would be 0.3 but
do you think Chris likes to be asked for
one number
no Chris doesn't like to represent his
one number Christ likes to give you the
whole probability of distribution
um and there's you know and one of the
nice things about that is that whole
probability distribution makes it easier
for me to update let's say they get
um
what if they got a really tiny letter
and they got it right that's so weird
like they got two they took a large
letter and they got it wrong they took a
larger letter and they got it right and
then they looked at a pretty tie letter
and got it right whoa can it handle that
absolutely after this is like okay I
have this pretty wide distribution but
now I'm starting to think that you can
actually see pretty well again and you
can put in any combination of beliefs
and you can update your belief
what a good way to estimate somebody's
ability yes
so if you run this in with real humans
after you've seen about 20 questions
your probably distribution looks like
this
and you're like I'm pretty sure except
if I don't know your person is like
super drunk and they're like not paying
attention like sometimes they're
guessing sometimes they're slipping and
after 20 questions if they've been all
over the place uh you may end up with
some more variants uh and that will
depend a lot on the person but most
people pretty low variants after 20
questions
this is not that important but there's
one thing I haven't told you like I've
told you everything about how we update
our belief about people's ability to see
what I haven't told you about is how do
you choose the next letter
I'm going to tell you the answer in
about two weeks I'll explain the deeper
Theory to why this is interesting
if you take any current belief and
ability to see there's another reason
why I like ability to C represented as a
belief let's say that's my belief and
ability to see it's not one number it's
a whole probability distribution
if I want to choose the next font size
you know what I do I do this thing
called optimistic sampling I take one
sample from ability to C I pull a sample
from this distribution
and then I ask what's the perfect font
size for that sample
it balances out exploration of whether
or not the person can see and taking
advantage of what I really believe they
can see
and it turns out to be a really nice
optimistic algorithm for coming up with
the next font size and that turns out
that other part of the problem is really
important to you but it has a nice
simple solution that nice Simple
Solution though requires you not to
express your belief as a number but
express your belief as a whole probably
distribution which is what everyone in
the world should be doing we should I'll
be talking about our beliefs somebody
says like oh what's the like when do you
think you're gonna get home I'm like
okay wife here's my whole chart of all
the times I can get home and my belief
distribution like that's how I'd like to
express everything if I could uh but
that's not very good with language
okay
um
I actually want to let us go a little
bit early but how cool is that you guys
have worked so hard to like build
fundamentals and practice your base
there I mean think about your base name
with random variables and now random
variables okay taking on lots of values
but it leads to this ability to write
programs that a lot of people seem to
not be able to write which is such a
cool thing have a fantastic day come
back on Wednesday we'll continue this
great conversation thank you guys so
much for working so hard foreign